qué tal bienvenidos hasta ahora en los
vídeos de probabilidad solo hemos usado
una definición y esta es que la
probabilidad de que un evento x ocurra o
la probabilidad de que algo se encuentra
en el conjunto x es igual al número de
eventos de eventos
que satisfacen x
satisfacen
x
es fácil
/ /
el número total
número total de eventos pero no sólo eso
eventos
queríamos que estos eventos fueran
igualmente probables
igualmente
probables asumimos que todos los eventos
tenían la misma probabilidad de ocurrir
de modo que por ejemplo con una moneda
justa la probabilidad de obtener un
águila era igual a que tenía dos eventos
posibles águila o sol los dos serán
igualmente probables
obtener aguilar a solo uno de esos dos
eventos o en el caso de un dado de un
dado justo de seis caras la probabilidad
de tirar un número par es decir que me
salga un número par era igual a pues
habían seis eventos distintos seis
números y tres de ellos son pares 2 4 y
6 por lo tanto esta probabilidad de 3
sextos era igual a un medio pero todo se
basaba en que todos los eventos serán
igualmente probables ahora voy a cambiar
la situación voy a cambiar la situación
radicalmente y en particular lo que voy
a hacer es deshacerme de esta suposición
de que los eventos son igualmente
probables comenzamos pensando en una
moneda ahí tengo una moneda
una moneda de oro
por aquí está la el águila
el tengo
bueno ese es mi intento de dibujar un
águila es una moneda que quizás no pesa
lo mismo de una cara que en la otra y
por lo tanto a veces cae más veces de un
lado así que voy a llamar al este lado
el águila y a la cara de atrás la voy a
llamar sol que es esencialmente lo mismo
que cara o cruz y en esta moneda y esto
es lo interesante voy a decir que la
probabilidad de obtener un águila ya no
va a ser de un medio ahora voy a decir
que es del 60% lo que es lo mismo es de
0.6 lo que es lo mismo es de 6 entre 10
que es igual a 3 entre 5 así que en este
caso la moneda de nuevo solo puede caer
en águila o en sol no se puede quedar
parada sobre su canto así que kayak y
lauca y sol pero definitivamente ya no
es cierto que los dos eventos son
igualmente probables ahora tiene una
tendencia un poco más alta de caer en
águila y el modo de interpretar esta
probabilidad el modo interpretar este
60% es pensar en la prueba
como una frecuencia si yo tuviera un
número grandísimo de monedas digamos mil
millones o diez mil millones o un
googleplex de monedas y pudieras echar
un volado simultáneamente con todas
esperaría que alrededor del 60 por
ciento de ellas caigan en águila a eso
se refiere esta probabilidad de aquí
para esta moneda injusta de nuevo pues
como decía también puede obtener sol y
cuál sería la probabilidad de obtener
sol la moneda sólo puede caer en águila
o en sol tiene que caer en alguno de los
dos y si cae en águila lógicamente no
puede caer el sol y si acá hay un sol no
puede caer en águila por lo tanto estos
eventos son mutuamente 10 juntos y esta
probabilidad es igual al 100 por ciento
menos la probabilidad de obtener águila
pero nosotros ya sabemos que la
probabilidad de obtener águila es de el
60 por ciento
por lo tanto la probabilidad de obtener
sol es igual a 100 menos 60 que es el
40%
que es lo mismo que 0.4 0.4 que es lo
mismo que 4 entre 10 o simplificando 2
entre 5 y de nuevo esto significa que
mientras más volados haga más esperaré
que el 40% de ellos sean sol no me
importa como hagan los volados y los
hago con una simulación por computadora
si realmente efectúa una cantidad
absurda de volados o si conozco física y
puedo tratar de hacer una especie de
modelo físico entonces esto a esto se
refiere la probabilidad y noten que es
un caso 100% distinto a éste ahora los
eventos no son igualmente probables
claramente no es la misma la
probabilidad de obtener águila que de
obtener sol bueno ya que tenemos esto
vamos a pensar en algunos problemas
bueno y comencemos pensando o
preguntándonos cuál es la probabilidad
de obtener un águila en el primer volado
y un águila en el segundo volado ahora
estos son eventos independientes no sé
si lo recuerdan de vídeos anteriores qué
significa eso que lo que pasa en el
primer volado no afecta al segundo
volado la moneda no tiene memoria por lo
tanto esta prueba
sería igual a la probabilidad de obtener
un águila en el primer volado
multiplicada por la probabilidad de
obtener un águila en el segundo volado
que esencialmente son la misma es la
probabilidad de obtener un águila sin
pensar en que volado estoy y cuánto es
eso pues la probabilidad de obtener un
águila en el primer volado es 0.6 esto
es 0.6 y la probabilidad de obtener un
águila en el segundo volado también es
de 0.6 así que esto es igual a origen me
lo hago por aquí es 0.6 por 0.6 0.6 es
un poco más de la mitad así que voy a
tomar un poco más de la mitad de 0.6 por
lo tanto debe ser un poquito más que 0.3
pero vamos a ver esencialmente lo que
hago es multiplicar olvidándome del
punto decimal y obtengo 6 por 6 36 y
luego simplemente cuento cuántos lugares
tengo antes del punto decimal tengo 1
dos lugares antes del punto decimal así
que el resultado de 0.36 que es
ligeramente superior a 0.3 que sería la
mitad de 0.6 así que la probabilidad de
obtener un águila en el primer volado y
un águila en el segundo es esencialmente
igual a
0.36 o al 36% que de nuevo no es algo
tan inesperado si hubiera sido una
moneda justa si hubiera sido una moneda
justa entonces hubiera sido el 25%
porque hubiera sido un medio por un
medio pero no es una moneda ajuste es
una moneda injusta así que tiene más
chance de sacar águila bueno pensemos en
algo un poco más complicado vamos a
pensar en la probabilidad de
vamos a pensar en la probabilidad de
obtener un sol en mi primer tiro después
un águila en mi segundo tiro y
finalmente un sol en mi tercer tiro y de
nuevo todos estos son eventos
independientes por lo tanto esto es
igual a la probabilidad de obtener un
sol en el primer tiro la probabilidad de
obtener un sol en cualquier volado todos
tienen la misma por la probabilidad de
obtener un obtener un águila en el
segundo volado que es la probabilidad de
obtener un águila por la probabilidad de
obtener un sol en el tercer volado y
cuánto es esto pues veamos la
probabilidad de obtener un sol en el
primer tiro es la probabilidad de
obtener un sol que es 0.4 así que esto
es 0.4
y lo tengo que multiplicar por la
probabilidad de un águila en el segundo
turno segundo tiro que es de 0.6
y finalmente lo multiplicó todo por la
probabilidad de obtener un sol que de
nuevo es de 0.4 y cuánto es esto pues
vamos a pensar que esencialmente lo que
voy a hacer es multiplicar 4 por 6 por 4
y tengo 3 números detrás del punto
decimal así que lo voy a recorrer tres
espacios 4 por 6 es 24 por 4 es 96 así
que tengo 96 pero tengo que recorrer el
punto o tres lugares 1 2 3 agregó un 0
me queda
0.0 96 que esencialmente es 9.6 por
ciento que es poco menos de 10 por
ciento que es poco menos de 1 entre 10
lo cual significa que la probabilidad de
obtener esta secuencia de tiros sol
águila sol en ese orden es poquito menos
de una entre 10